[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo une demi heure pour revenir sur
les temps forts de l'actualité à
l'assemblée et au sénat est aujourd'hui
avec kathia gilder notre invité pour
faire le bilan de la semaine et le
député les républicains du lot
aurélien pradié bonjour bonjour vous
êtes également candidat aux régionales
en occitanie et c'est katia qui vous
présente
bonjour aurélien pradié merci d'être
avec nous vous avez 35 ans vous avez 35
ans la politique vous a toujours
passionné vous aimez raconté que quand
les autres avait des posters de batman
vous c'était plutôt jacques chirac
vous avez fait vos enfants votre entrée
à l'assemblée en 2017 et portait deux
textes de société importants l'un pour
l'inclusion des élèves en situation de
handicap puis une proposition de loi
contre les violences au sein de la
famille qui est votée à l'unanimité de
tous les groupes politiques et
promulguée en 2019
aurélien pradié c'est l'un de vos grands
combats il ya encore eu un fumi six
lycéens féminicide épouvantable près de
bordeaux une mère de famille brûlées
vives et des associations apprend
appelle à prendre d'autres mesures
urgent est ce que votre loi et les lois
qui ont été votées pour stopper les
violences conjugales sont impuissantes
un stopper ce fléau
il faut aller plus loin ce qui s'est
passé à mérignac est monstrueux on est
vous compte que ce monstre là à brûler
une mère de deux enfants son épouse
qu'il avait été condamné par le passé à
neuf mois de prison ferme pour les mêmes
faits pour les mêmes faits que ce
monstre la a été libéré en anticipation
vous m'entendez libéré en anticipation
que ce monstre là avait toujours des
armes qui ne lui avait pas été retiré
bref nous sommes en génération voué à
quelque chose qui n'a pas fonctionné le
système l'instant la loi le système
judiciaire ne fonctionne pas soyons
clairs nets et précis la loi dont vous
parliez donc tout à fait fière que nous
avons porté permettait notamment de
généraliser le bracelet anti
rapprochement pour protéger les femmes
de celles et ceux qui veulent veulent
les tuer
pourquoi cet individu n'a pas su de
bracelet anti rapprochement il est dans
la loi
moi je peux pas faire plus que la loi je
n'ai loin
comment cette loi vous appeler à
davantage d'application parce qu'on a
dit il y avait vous en avait parlé il y
avait le bracelet anti rapprochement le
téléphone grave danger les ordonnances
de protection ya de nombreux outils ils
ne sont pas aujourd'hui utilisée sur le
terrain la suppression du port d'armes
c'est dans la loi que nous avons voté
pour aller beaucoup plus loin là
pourquoi elle n'a pas été appliquée il
nous manque une autre étape celle que
j'appelle de mes voeux depuis plusieurs
mois c'est la création d'une juridiction
spécialisée
qu'est ce qui fait que l'espagne
notamment a pris une avance considérable
sur nous depuis des années c'est certes
le bracelet anti rapprochement qui les
avait bien avant nous et je suis heureux
que nous ayons pu porter cette loi pour
enfin le généraliser mais c'est aussi la
juridiction spécialisée c'est à dire une
juridiction comme aujourd'hui on a un
juge des enfants qui s'occupe
spécifiquement des enfants qui est
capable demain qui serait capable de
mano s'occuper spécifiquement des
violences conjugales pour aller vite et
pour agir
durement et fermement j'ai plaidé auprès
de nicole belloubet à l'époque pour la
création de cette juridiction
spécialisée elle a refusé
j'ai plaidé auprès de eric dupond
moretti il a fait semblant de ne pas
entendre la proposition maintenant ça
suffit
ou bien on passe des paroles aux actes
ou bien tous les mois tous les ans on va
continuer à compter le nombre de femmes
qui sont assassinés et c'est
insupportable si la politique a bien un
sens c'est notamment sur des combats
comme cela aurait un tradi on va passer
au titre de cette émission d confiné
sans se priver des moyens d'imposer de
nouvelles restrictions c'est le
difficile équilibre que le gouvernement
tente de trouver en commission les
députés ont adopté le projet loi qui
ouvre notamment la voix ou pas ce
solitaire
le sénat propose une nouvelle rédaction
pour inscrire la préservation de
l'environnement non de la constitution
sa version est moins contraignante pour
les entreprises et les collectivités
l'espoir d'un accord avec l'assemblée
est très mince et puis un rapport
parlementaire propose une légalisation
réglementée du cannabis récréatif pour
permettre à l'état de reprendre le
contrôle
sur la production la consommation de
cette substance et on commence par le
projet de loi de sortie de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire examiné en
commission à l'assemblée
[Musique]
oui le texte a été adopté par les
députés de la commission des lois avec
des modifications le projet de loi
encadre la mise en place d'un pass
sanitaires pour accéder à certains lieux
les députés ont en revanche encadrer la
possibilité de confinement locaux des
territoires avec contrôle démocratique
mario becker sortir de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire tout en continuant à lutter
contre l'épidémie
c'est la difficile équation débattu
entre le gouvernement et parfois même sa
majorité le régime transitoire défendue
par olivier ferrand prévoit la mise en
place d'un pass sanitaire obligatoire
pour certains déplacements ou
rassemblements au considère que ça
pourrait être mille personnes des grands
rassemblements pour des activités de
loisirs ou des foires ou des salons
professionnels c'est-à-dire des
situations il va y avoir une forte
concentration de population avec un
brassage de population important
j'ajoute que cette règle cette rédaction
exclut de fait tout usage d'un pass
sanitaires pour des activités de la vie
courante
l'opposition mais aussi la majorité
attendait davantage de clarté sur les
événements concernés sans réponse à ce
stade
l'autre mesure phare du projet de loi
c'est la possibilité de déclencher
déconfinement locaux pendant l'été et
d'une durée de deux mois
une durée jugée inadmissible en
commission par les députés qui nous
paraît honnêtement anormalement long
c'est un mois dans l'état d'urgence
sanitaire un mois c'est déjà assez long
avec des mesures complètement exorbitant
du droit commun pour ceux qui les
subiront nous ne souhaitons pas donner à
l'exécutif un pouvoir supplémentaire et
nous souhaitons que le parlement garde
des prérogatives constitutionnelles qui
sont les siennes
c'est à dire qu'au bout d'un mois il est
reconvoqué étaient ou pas été les
parlementaires ont toujours été présents
le sujet fera à nouveau débat dans
l'hémicycle
il sera examiné dès lundi à l'assemblée
aurélien pradié le projet de loi nous
fait sortir de l'état d'urgence tout en
donnant à l'exécutif et au préfet les
moyens de décider de confinement locaux
si la situation sanitaire se dégrade sur
un territoire précis est ce que ces deux
objectifs sont pour joue compatibles je
suis très
est très inquiet de la manière dont
depuis de longs - désormais nous nous
habituant une forme dégradée de notre
démocratie
il faut dire les choses notre démocratie
ne fonctionnent plus normalement depuis
plus d'un an
d'abord les libertés n'ont jamais été
aussi réduite et il navré de vous dire
que je ne souhaite pas continuer à vivre
dans une société qui prive de ses
libertés fondamentales la liberté de
circulation d'aller et de venir de se
réunir de faire ce que l'on veut de sa
vie face à projet de loi de sortie de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire est ce que
pour vous 5 vraiment de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire avec c'est tout le problème
c'est que c'est une fausse sortie on
n'en sort pas vous l'avez vu dans dans
votre sujet qui est parfaitement fait le
pouvoir exécutif ça hier sans contrôle
du parlement sans contrôle les
représentants du peuple que sont les
députés va pouvoir décider de
confinement locaux de deux mois pour
vous ce n'est pas démocratique
non ce n'est pas démocratique ce n'est
pas le fonctionnement normal de notre
démocratie et le devoir d'un député cdh
aujourd'hui rappelé que la règle
fondamentale c'est d'abord de sortir des
privations de liberté je ne veux pas de
cette société dans laquelle de manière
continuelle sans que nous n'ayons la
moindre discussion nous soyons privée de
nos libertés fondamentales et que à tout
le moins il faut que les parlementaires
le parlement c'est l'organisation de
notre démocratie
contrôler ces privations de liberté on
donne des pouvoirs exorbitants au chef
de l'état au premier ministre qui décide
tout seul dans un conseil de défense
rendez vous comme ce conseil de défense
aujourd'hui il a remplacé le conseil des
ministres mais qui pourtant
l'organisation institutionnelle de notre
pays enfin on peut pas continuer sans
déranger avec un simple compte-rendu
secret autour de prison de la république
choisit qui serait uni autour de la
table il n'y a pas de compte rendu
public comme ça doit être le cas en
conseil des ministres j'ai signé il ya
quelques semaines une tribune dans un
quotidien national pour m'interroger sur
le fait que peut-être nous n'aimons plus
la liberté
et moi je suis un de ceux qui aiment
encore la liberté et mon devoir de
députés titres parfois aller contre
certaines mesures absolument sanitaire
d'expliquer que la liberté est tout
aussi fondamental que la santé justement
soir sur le past and i ter pour le coup
est ce que pour vous c'est la bonne
solution pour essayer de retrouver le
chemin de la vie normale je suis très
réservé sur le pass sanitaires d'abord
le pass sanitaires il ne peut exister
que si tout le monde a pu être vaccinés
il est rappelé que j'ai 35 ans avant que
moi même qui n'est pas de signes de
comorbidité jeu soit vacciné il va se
passer quelques scènes quelques lui
n'est pas que les vaccins le pass
sanitaire c'est aussi pouvoir maintenir
un test qui n est bien sûr où la preuve
que l'on est bien sûr pensé pour avoir
une permission d'aller partout c'est la
vaccination qui vous permettrait de le
faire dans le cadre du pass annie terre
quant aux tests
on évoquait tout à l'heure la vie
quotidienne côté moi aller dans un
concert aller dans une salle de
spectacle allez dans une foire ça fait
partie de la vie quotidienne la vie
quotidienne s'est pas seulement aller
travailler est rentré chez soi dont je
suis très réservé à l'égard de ces
outils qui vont fracturé la société
écrit plusieurs catégories pour vous ce
pass sanitaire c'est une manière
d'instaurer des discriminations comme
d'anti certains d péter à l'évidence oui
prenons les exemples qui ont été donnés
les grandes manifestations les grands
concerts de quelques milliers de
personnes je fais une parenthèse
d'ailleurs nous ne savons toujours pas
quels sont les événements qui vont être
concernées c'est quand même tout à fait
inouï le gouvernement a proposé un texte
dans lequel il est incapable aujourd'hui
de nous dire précisément quels seront
les événements confirment et justement
les discothèques et discothèques n'ont
pas le droit de rouvrir ne font pas
partie du projet de loi pour vous est ce
que il faudrait ouvrir les discothèques
et à quelles conditions
ce que je souhaite à sanitaires ce que
je souhaite c'est que nous retrouvions
le plus tôt possible une vie sociale
normale et je sais que c'est pas facile
à dire mais tous les lieux publics dans
tout ce qui fait la vie de notre pays et
les discothèques même si je vous avoue
que ça fait longtemps j'y suis pas allé
je considère que ça fait partie où tout
le monde la vie tout le monde que ça
fait partie de la vie de notre société
et donc on peut pas continuellement
s'habituer à ce qu'au fond la culture
deviennent secondaires la vie sociale
deviennent secondaires et qu'il ne reste
que le pass sanitaire le travail et le
confinement chez soi c'est un supporter
à une toute dernière question la levée
de les brevets sur les vaccins elle fait
son chemin c'est plus une simple lubie
de la gauche qui la demandait depuis
extrêmement longtemps sans pays de mc
voilà qu emmanuel macron dans le sillage
de jo by daniel favorable et vous c'est
une bonne nouvelle
y a pas que la gauche qui demandaient la
levée des brevets sur la question des
vaccins c'est fondamental nous sommes
sur des enjeux de santé planétaire n'est
pas question de faire du business sur
ces questions là je le dis comme je le
pense mais pas de commerces à faire sur
ces sujets philippe juvin
le demander à droite déjà depuis
plusieurs mois et le gouvernement à
l'époque se foutait de nous en disant
mais non vous n'y connaissez rien c'est
impossible
eh bien il lui a suffi que le président
des états unis d'amérique le dise pour
que emmanuel macron emboîtent le pas
donc on suit on est à la remorque des
états unis si on est à la remorque des
états unis comme d'ailleurs d'autres
pays mais si ce gouvernement depuis
plusieurs mois écouter un peu ces
oppositions moi je ne suis pas d'accord
avec emmanuel macron mais durant toute
la crise sanitaire nous avons fait des
propositions
ils n'en n'ont pas écouté une seule et
tout ce qu'ils font aujourd'hui c'est ce
que nous avions proposé hier alors on va
passer aurélien pradié au deuxième thème
de cette émission le sénat qui propose
sa propre rédaction pour inscrire la
protection de l'environnement à
l'article 1 de la constitution
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le diable est dans les détails la
commission des lois du sénat a supprimé
le mot qui fâche dans la version du
gouvernement leterme garantir jugeant
qu'ils introduisent une obligation de
résultats trop contraignant pour les
sénateurs jérôme ralliez vous explique
tout ça comme la convention citoyenne
l'avait voulu emmanuel macron s'est
engagé à modifier l'article 1 de la loi
fondamentale en inscrivant ces termes la
république garantit la préservation de
la biodiversité de l'environnement et
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
une version que l'assemblée nationale a
déjà adopté
mais pour la droite sénatoriale le verbe
garantir fait peser trop de risques je
crois sérieusement que le verbe garantir
porte en lui les germes de grandes
difficultés concernent la constitution
et de doutes sur le caractère sur son
application réalité donc cela il faut
l'éviter
il a donc fait voter une modification de
cette phrase qui devient pour la
majorité sénatoriale la france préserve
l'environnement ainsi que la diversité
biologique et agit contre le dérèglement
climatique dans les conditions prévues
par la charte de l'environnement de 2004
pour les élus en marche
cela bloque tout compromis sur la
question la droite choisit une
opposition tacticienne politicienne pour
empêcher l'adoption de ce texte je le
regrette parce que l'urgence climatique
mérite mieux problème pour aboutir un
référendum il faut que l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat vote cette
modification dans les mêmes termes
ce qui devient maintenant illusoire au
grand dam des écologistes de côté la
droite républicaine ici au sénat d'un
autre côté le gouvernement emmanuel
macron qui en fait vos chacun s'appuyer
sur les réserves de l'autre partie pour
expliquer qu'en fait c'est bien eux qui
portent le changement mais que ces
désordres qu'ils veulent pas voilà alors
faut arrêter ce jeu de dupes
le texte sera examiné en séance en début
de semaine prochaine sans doute pour
acté définitivement deux versions
irréconciliables et l'impossibilité
d'aboutir à un référendum sur la
question
donc on va faire un peu de sémantique 1
la version du sénat prévoit donc que la
france préserve l'environnement ainsi
que la diversité biologique et a agi
contre le dérèglement climatique
les conditions prévues par la charte de
l'environnement de 2004 en quoi pour
vous cette rédaction est elle meilleure
que celle du gouvernement a beaucoup de
joueuses qui disent c'est ni mieux ni
pire je sais d'accord c'est ni mieux ni
pire mais le sujet il est ailleurs
pendant qu emmanuel macron amuse la
galerie avec cette phrase là avec le
choix de mots la question climatique
n'est pas traité la question climatique
elle est fondamentale et c'est un élu de
droite qui vous le dit jacques chirac a
été celui qui le premier dans la
constitution a écrit avec la charte de
l'environnement et on oublie emmanuel
macron vient comme une fleur aujourd'hui
nous expliquer qu'il va réécrire la
constitution jacques chirac l'a fait en
2004 et c'est largement suffisant
les enjeux climatiques ce sont ceux-là
conciliation du développement humain du
développement économique et de la
préservation de l'environnement
et c'est autrement plus difficile que de
glisser un mot dans la couche justement
aurélien pradié ce qu'il ya une
contradiction entre cette charte de
l'environnement dont vous parlez qui
fait partie de ce qu'on appelle le bloc
de constitutionnalité cela des textes à
valeur constitutionnelle ce qui est la
contradiction entre cette charte et le
texte proposé par le gouvernement
emmanuel macron ne propose rien d'autre
qu'un gadget politique ça sert à rien on
a déjà ce qu'il faut dans la
constitution ce qu'il faut en revanche
c'est une volonté politique de préserver
l'environnement et de concilier la
préservation de l'environnement et le
développement économique vous et je le
vois dans un territoire comme le mien
dans cette région d'occitanie tous les
jours nous avons des combats à mener
entre des intégristes écologistes qui
s'intéresse à tout sauf à
l'environnement et sont ceux qui veulent
supprimer le tour de france
supprimer la viande à la cantine et qui
pendant ce temps là ne s'occupe pas la
vraie question par exemple l'accès à
l'eau pour nos agriculteurs
moi je suis favorable à ce qu'on traite
cette question là pour récupérer de
l'eau quand elles tombent du ciel et
qu'on n'a pas besoin et l'utiliser quand
on en a besoin s'appelle des lacs
collinaires les écologistes intégristes
y sont opposés ils y sont opposés alors
que c'est une mesure de protection et de
préservation de l'environnement
on a ce débat sur les éoliennes dans ma
région je me suis engagé à m'opposer à
tout nouveau projet d'éolien terrestre
nous avons des intégristes écologiste
aujourd'hui qui pousse l'éolien alors
que c'est une aberration
environnementale est une aberration
économique
et voilà les sujets qu'il faut traiter
agir concrètement et pas faire des
phrases issues d'accords mère du coup
lorsque les élèves au sénat
et bien joue justement retoucher le
texte ce qu'ils font ce n'est pas plus
utile que ce que fait emmanuel macron en
jouant sur la sémantique qu'est-ce que
caisse qui gagne l'écologie à faire cela
pas grand chose
là où les sénateurs ont raison c'est de
dire que la manière dont on va écrire la
phrase dans le texte constitutionnel
peut empêcher le développement de
beaucoup de projets par exemple la
manière dont on écrit le texte version
emmanuel macron pourrait empêcher les
grands projets routiers les grands
projets de lgv
or moi je veux de même nous ayons des
grands projets routiers et des grands
projets de lgv et c'est la règle
vraiment on a l'impression plutôt on dit
il ya une obligation de résultat est ce
que c'est pas cela aussi qu'il il
faudrait vraiment inscrire dans la
constitution à ce qu'il n'est pas temps
quand on voit et bien que la france émet
toujours beaucoup trop de gaz à effet de
serre par rapport à ce qu'elle promet
sans cesse chaque gène et tout cela ce
sont les questions faciles on sait
plaisir en venant des phrases la réalité
c'est comment on va sur le terrain
comment on traite la question de l'eau
pour nos agriculteurs comment on traite
aujourd'hui l'accès à des produits de
proximité
comment est ce qu'on fait de même par
exemple que dans les marchés publics on
achète d'abord des produits de proximité
plutôt que des produits à l'étranger
voilà des vrais sujets sur lesquels il
faut que nous politique nous travaillons
et sur lesquels je souhaite travailler
alors pour inscrire le climat dans la
constitution il faut un accord entre
assemblée et sénat un texte identique
votée par les deux chambres
est ce que pour vous un accord est
encore possible ou pas je l'espère parce
que tout ce qui permettra de faire
avancer la question environnementale est
positif mais ça doit pas se faire au
prix d'une idéologie
environnementalistes d'une idéologie
décroissante qui est celle de josé bové
et compagnie
ce n'est pas ma vision des choses je
souhaite porter ce que la droite a
toujours porté la conciliation de
l'environnement qui est notre patrimoine
le plus cher auquel nous sommes attachés
et le développement humain notamment
économiques et des emplois elle et on
termine avec le troisième thème de cette
émission le rapport sur le cannabis
présenté à l'assemblée
[Musique]
le rapport de la mission parlementaire a
été élaboré par caroline janvier députés
elle est à m
et son collègue hélène robin reda il
propose de légaliser le cannabis
récréatif sous certaines conditions les
coudes caroline janvier on propose de
reprendre le contrôle en légalisant mais
avec une légalisation encadrée à réguler
considérant que la légalisation et la
meilleure façon de prévenir les risques
associés au cannabis et de rétablir la
sécurité
donc finalement de protéger les français
et de prévenir les risques sanitaires
associés à la consommation de drogue ne
crois qu'on s'est longtemps tromper de
débat sur la question du cannabis en
considérant que légaliser était une
façon de promouvoir ou de banaliser le
cannabis alors même qu'il est en tout
cas c'est ma conviction le meilleur
moyen de limiter de prévenir les risques
associés à sa consommation
damien abad président votre groupe à
l'assemblée votre collègue hélène robin
reda président de cette mission
d'information sur le cannabis sont pour
une légalisation peut-être à rebours de
la position traditionnelle de la droite
qu'elle et vous votre position j'y suis
totalement opposé et je dis les choses
très clairement
d'abord je ne supporte pas cette
expression de cannabis récréatif le
cannabis n'est pas récréatif c'est pas
une récréation c'est une consommation de
stupéfiants c'est une drogue qui fait
des ravages chez la jeune génération
j'étais il ya quelques jours dans un
lycée de ma région et je constatais une
fois de plus à quel point la
consommation de cannabis devant les
portes des lycées
c'était banaliser la loi elle a deux
deux objectifs d'abord une force et une
charge symbolique
la loi c'est un message adressé à la
société lorsque vous portez proposer une
loi de légalisation du cannabis vous
adresser directement à la société un
message de méthanisation
c'est cette consommation par les
encadrer autant que vous voulez le
premier message c'est la force
symbolique de la loi qui est un message
négatif en matière de santé publique sur
ce sujet mais ce que l'on faisait
m'inscrire et steve actuelle n'est pas
quand même un échec est ce que vous
reconnaissez pas qu'aujourd'hui vous le
dit on à banaliser la consommation du
cannabis on avec des grands problèmes de
sécurité il faut bien proposer quelque
chose pour évoluer nous sommes d'accord
il faut que nous allions plus loin sur
et la prévention notamment dans les
établissements scolaires je le dis dans
les lycées il faut demain que nous
investissions avec des équipes qui vont
bien de faire de la sensibilisation sur
la consommation de cannabis et pas
seulement eu de la france etat c est
assez bien placé dans les dents les
champions d'europe de consommation de
cannabis
oui bien sûr mais en termes de
prévention elle n'est pas championne du
tout plu et la répression vous aussi
lorsque je propose dans ma région pardon
de vous en parler parce que c'est un peu
ma préoccupation du moment que l'on ait
des bulles de sécurité autour de tous
les lycées de la région occitanie pour
empêcher la consommation aux portes des
lycées
c'est une manière aussi de lutter contre
cela moi j'ai une opposition profonde à
cette idée de l'égalisation ce n'est pas
la vision et l'idée que je me fais de la
société et j'ai beau avoir 35 ans je
suis très attaché à ses principes est
alors un policier a été tué à avignon
dans un quartier trafic de drogue
emmanuel macron a fait de l'éradication
de trafic de stups la mer des campagnes
ce que vous pensez que l'insécurité
contrat pour la présidentielle de 2000
elle comptera comme elle compte depuis
de nombreuses années la société a perdu
tous ses repères tous ses repères ça
vaut dans la vie politique avec les
girouettes à répétition et ça vaut aussi
dans l'ordre public nous avons cette
situation aujourd'hui je veux dire aux
forces de l'ordre
à quel point aujourd'hui nous leur
devons plus que des mots de soutien
alors devant des actes vous avez parlé
de la perte de repères à une autre
question politique pour terminer vous
êtes secrétaire général des républicains
votre famille politique avec un
véritable psychodrame dans le cadre des
régionales en paca cette semaine les
derniers répercussions c'est les départs
de votre parti d'hubert falco
christian estrosi on apprend que sophie
cluzel est à nouveau candidate en paca
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
est-ce qui a pas aussi une part de
désagrégation de votre famille politique
face à tout cela
ça m'inspire beaucoup de consternation
tout ça est misérable sommes dans une
vie politique aujourd'hui qui a perdu
ses codes d'honneur
désormais on peut trahir sa famille
politique pour aller à la gamelle de
manière aussi banal que saab et moi je
n'aime pas ça vous parlez de qui de
christian estrosi mende et renaud
muselier vous parlez de voir le
christian estrosi je parle de tous ceux
y compris côté rassembleur national
thierry mariani jean paul garraud dans
ma région qui ont une colonne vertébrale
aussi forte que des jeunes chiens devant
un sac de croquettes et qui parce qu'ils
ne réussissent pas dans leur famille
politique parce que c'est trop compliqué
d'être fidèles à leurs idées vont à la
soupe chez les autres pardon je suis dur
et parce que je pense que ce qui
désespère nos concitoyens de la
politique c'est odile eux aussi le fait
que les responsables politiques sont
devenus aujourd'hui des petites
girouette et je n'aime pas ça et si je
me suis engagé en politique c'est aussi
par fidélité par loyauté c'est dur
aujourd'hui d'être de droite mais c'est
parce que c'est dur qu'il faut avoir le
courage de l'être et c'est pour ça que
j'ai toujours refusé d'aller à la soupe
et que je vous le dis devant l'ensemble
de celles et ceux qui nous écoutent
autant aussi longtemps je ferai de la
politique je refuse également encore une
question estrosi demande justement à
élire une clarification de votre parti
vis-à-vis du rassemblement national lui
ai dit c'est pas que je vais à la soupe
c'est que aujourd'hui elles ne sont pas
claires dans leurs positions dans leur
opposition au rassemblement national s
qui a besoin mais nous sommes très
clairs je suis candidat en région
occitanie g contre au moins un transfuge
deux des républicains de l'ump qui parce
qu'il a été battu à l'ump et elle est la
soupe chez le rassemblement national et
j'ai en face de moi un transfuge qui a
fait la même chose côté à l'ère où m
mais je tiens la barre je tiens là bas
et je ne transige ni avec les hommes ni
avec les autres je n'ai rien à voir avec
leur assemblée nationale je comprends
que certains électeurs puissent se
perdre dans le vote du rassemblement
national
mais ce qui les représente au
rassemblement national sont des
imposteurs il s'intéresse à tout sauf à
l'avenir de nos concitoyens
c'est mon boulot de députés républicains
je suis dur parce que parce que j'en ai
marre parce que j'en ai marre de voir
aujourd'hui
d'un côté comme de l'autre des
opportunistes politiques qui se font
passer pour des femmes et des hommes
courageux ils sont tout sauf courageux
et il faut réhabiliter le courage
politique dire à nos concitoyens que oui
sur les questions de sécurité
oui sur les question d'injustice sociale
de violence conjugale de handicap
la droite républicaine doit dire quelque
chose il ne faut surtout pas laisser
celles et ceux qui sont des imposteurs
politique faire semblant de s'intéresser
à ce sujet moi je suis là pour apporter
des solutions à mes concitoyens et avoir
une colonne vertébrale si on prend
justement pas qu'à ce que vous ne
craignez pas que votre électorat et
l'air est bien puisse aller plus
facilement aujourd'hui vers le
rassemblement national incarné bien par
thierry mariani un ex cadres de l'ump
lorsqu'on a l'impression d'un que l air
lrm sont si proches même si honnêtement
on est complètement perdu aujourd'hui on
ne sait même plus quoi penser de la
situation je combats le projet politique
d' emmanuel macron depuis je suis à
l'assemblée nationale par sectarisme
bien parce que je mets parce que je ne
partage pas son projet politique quand
elle manuel macron dit qu'il veut
déconstruire l'histoire de france je ne
suis pas d'accord avec lui quand il à
cette arrogance et ce caractère injuste
à l'égard de la société je ne suis pas
d'accord avec lui voilà pourquoi je suis
de droite la droite républicaine que je
suis et je ne suis ni l'extrême droite
ni macro ni sts et c'est à la droite
républicaine de tracer son chemin
si nous nous faisons confiance nous
mêmes alors nos concitoyens finiront par
nous faire un nouveau tombé merci
beaucoup et bien précis donc le mot de
la fin merci nous avons donné votre
regard sur l'actualité parlementaire de
la semaine on se retrouve très
prochainement très bonne site deux
programmes cha cha
[Musique]